Oh
CES was a little more muted this year
than in past years with fewer attendees
and not as many exciting product
introductions but despite that we were
still able to find a few really cool
things out on the show floor everybody
expected lots of 3d TVs and CES did not
disappoint but the coolest one we saw
was the cell TV from Toshiba now this
thing has multiple eight core processors
inside it's probably about ten times as
powerful as your desktop PC and what
they use that power for is taking 2d
video content and converting it up to 3d
on the fly there are a lot of eBook
readers from the likes of plastic logic
skiff entourage and others one of the
things that was interesting about these
things this year is that they're getting
bigger instead of being about the size
of an index card they're now about the
size of an eight and a half by 11 inch
sheet of paper and many of them even
have touchscreen capabilities he can
draw one of the things that really blew
us away was a semi-transparent OLED
display from Samsung now this thing is
display like a notebook screen but it's
40 percent transparent so you can see
what's going on behind it it looks like
something out of Minority Report or
avatar it's amazing manufacturers seem
to think that if you'd like one of
something you'd probably want to so we
saw in a sous netbook that has two touch
pads and there were lots of devices that
have two screens on them like the
entourage
edge the out spring designs alex eReader
the Barnes and Noble Nook has two
screens it's like what is up with this
people two of everything do we really
need that another trend is the smart
book now this is like a super small
notebook or netbook except it's running
a cell phone like processor and has
built-in 3G wireless data capability the
coolest one I saw was lenovo's skylight
it's pretty and slim
and lightweight and they say it'll run
all day about eight hours single battery
charge the show had its share of low
lights - starting with Microsoft's
keynote which kicked off the show 20
minutes late thanks to a power failure
backstage that plunged the stage into
darkness commenters on wired comm
nicknamed this the black stage of death
and then there was Sony this is a
company that's so old and out of it that
they felt like they had to gussy things
up any way they could they trotted out
Taylor Swift to kick off their press
conference they have a blog oriented
flip style camera which they're calling
the blog II hello and they showed off a
bunch of 3d TV stuff which actually
doesn't exist yet despite the downturn
in the economy everybody is still trying
to get a foothold in tech p-diddy and
Lady gaga have their own head phones now
and even Edie Hardy is trying to get in
on the act with his own line of blinged
out cases for your gadgets
you